guys when it comes to Tekken these days
you can pretty much win with any
character in the game
but it wasn't always so
in fact the Tekken series has given us
some of the most broken characters of
all time
which obviously gave us the idea for
this list now before we get into it guys
just so you know for our purposes broken
doesn't necessarily mean most powerful
these are characters who in some way or
another
fundamentally broke the games they
appeared in and when it comes to certain
characters let's just say the jury's
still out on the whole broken thing
anyways before we go ahead and award our
top 10 most broken Tekken characters of
all time I gotta let you know that we
have an award show it's coming up on
January the 15th so don't forget to be
there let's just say a certain tekken
god is up for a very prestigious award
and that's all I'm gonna say about that
let's get into the list starting us off
is none other than Tekken sevens first
and so far strongest guest character
Akuma and this street fighter transplant
has been a problem since day one nobody
goes for the orbital that gets punished
they're nice with footage from the Wow
look at this damage oh my god I just
looked up at the bar and look at the
wall here that's gonna do a ton of
damage is that gonna be enough oh my god
the issue with Akuma is that he just
doesn't play by the rules of Tekken yes
he has crazy damage but he also has
tools that no other character has Akuma
just sort of does it all
it's party time and the chickens invited
oh why did you say that bug I wanna
sleep party oh my god let's go I company
what we're seeing a
at the light bomb oh my goodness
whoa oh my let's go he survived plenty
of nerfs and although he might not be
the absolute best in the game he does
fundamentally break it and that means he
deserves a spot on this list number nine
in our list is Lars from Tekken 6 now
Lars was new in that game built as a
beginner friendly gateway character and
usually in fighting game designers make
those easy characters relatively weak
but not Lars
[Music]
Namco gave Lars built-in movement on
most of his moves on top of weird ducks
in the middle of a ton of his most
important attacks the problem was that
it made Lars unoffensive machine with
built-in defense and movements he had
crazy damage amazing range great
tracking and he crushed everything
honestly guys this video could have been
made up of 10 different characters from
Tekken 2 but Kazuya was a broken
character among broken characters which
is why he comes in at number eight from
our list in a game we're just about half
the cast can you kill you in one hit and
most throws shave off half your life it
seems like it would be difficult for a
single Tekken 2 character to stand out
well Kazuya did he boasted huge damage
on his juggles a wind-god fist that hit
mid and twin Pistons that were safe on
block and combo Don hit then of course
there was the missed step which
basically let him have exclusive access
to sidestepping and all kinds of
advanced movement even with all the
damage in the world the rest of the cast
just couldn't keep up now Tekken 2 isn't
the only game with loads of potential
for this list the very first Tekken game
is full of characters we could talk
about but for the number 7 spot looking
at Heihachi Mishima himself
[Music]
before he got old and his pair went gray
hey Hachi was an absolute monster in
Tekken one if you got launched the game
was over hey Hachi could take nearly
your entire life Bart in one combo and
outright kill you in one hit if he
landed a wind god fist and of course he
brought the original all-powerful twin
Pistons to the table great damage grape
oaks and a touch of death Tekken 1 hey
Hachi was unstoppable it's no wonder he
survived being thrown in the volcano
[Music]
now Bob might not look like the kind of
character that breaks an entire game but
appearances can be deceiving Tekken's
resident thick Ladd was an unstoppable
force in Tekken 6 which is why he takes
the number six spot on our list with
insane damage crazy pressure an easy
combos Bob literally did it all he had
every single tool at his disposal with
basically no weaknesses
you want a he'll sweep the juggles sure
have it you want easy high damage wall
combos Tekken 6 bomb had those four days
and then basically they buffed him for
Tekken 6 bloodline rebellion Bob really
does have the perfect body you might not
like it but this is what peak Tekken
performance looks like Tekken Tag
Tournament was a balanced nightmare of a
fighting game with a top tier that
completely dwarfed the competition but
jin jin had them all beat he's the
number 5 spot on our list
it's easy to point to his damage since
he had commas that regularly did half
the life bar on most of the cast whether
he started the combo or tagged in to
finishing but the real nightmare was his
electric wind godfist
that gin tag cancelled the move it
became a mid for some reason beating all
attempts to crush it and getting a sweet
counter hit launched to tag combo as a
bonus Jin also had solid 50/50 s ferry
throws great range nice pokes that
actually he had everything Jesus what a
character let's return to Tekken 1 for
our number 4 entry and talk about King
because he has one of the most busted
moves in Tekken history down forward one
is an alright folk on hit but a block
it's plus 93 and if it's blocked you
follow up with the combo but if it hits
you do I'm not Rodolfo block now for
those known up in their frame data that
means King has a full second and a half
to do whatever the hell he wants to do
and you're stuck waiting for him to do
it it leads to juggles and King can
basically kill you in two combos making
is down forward one one of the only
moves in fighting games history that
you'd rather get hit by than block who
doesn't love a good old infinite combo
attack in fives iteration of Steve
featured a game breaking one which earns
him a spot in our top three
in Tekken 5 steep could get some pretty
massive side steps by combining the
games mechanics with his own personal
sway this let him get side turned hits
on anyone throwing out pokes sites that
manage to step one of your attacks you
die
yes Baptists all guarantee now once he
had them side turned all he had to do
was 3 1 1 cancel the last one do another
side step and repeat until the opponent
was dead
second three is where Tekken truly
became its own unique series but that
doesn't mean it didn't have any broken
[ __ ] and this character in
particular was busted enough for the
runner-up spot on our list the boss
character known as ogre quickly became
Tekken threes one and only as tear
thanks to a single move waning moon
waiting moon was an unbreakable grab
which meant that once he had you in it
there was just no escape now most
unbreakable grabs have a lot of startup
to make up for their power but not
waning moon ogre started to grab in
twelve frames in this game you cannot
break it so this is a twelve frame high
unbreakable a waning moon that cannot be
broken that's never a good idea if you
blocked or if auger hit you with three
four you were getting waning moon for
nearly half your life bar no that's not
a joke ochre also had an unblockable
OneTouch kill various fast unblockable
moves and he just [ __ ] out damage like
no other character in the game
it's time to wrap up our list with demos
busted Tekken character of all time
there are a couple of insane tricks that
Tekken for Jin has up his sleeve but
they all pale in comparison to one move
likely the best one in Tekken history
just frame laser scraper there we go now
this is completely unavoidable there's
nothing you can do the trick was simple
charge up Jin slow but unblockable laser
scraper uppercut but release it on the
first frame of the charge getting an
instant unblockable uppercut that
launched and could not be ducked Tekken
4 grand finals at Evo 2004 work of
course a gym mirror and it was basically
a contest to see which player could hit
J FLS more times a lot of folks have
gone positive memories of Tekken 4 but
each and every one of them will curse
Jin's name when you mentioned J FLS it
is the most broken move in Tekken
history and it made Jin a force to be
reckoned with well guys that's our list
now you tell me in the comments section
did we miss someone like someone really
specific like someone who studied Wing
Chun for decades the battle crime in the
streets of New York like some lose
fundamentally breaking Tekken 7 don't
tell me tweet Harada and maybe together
we can all save Tekken 7 from the Leroy
menace ok let's see mr. Hirata all i
want for christmas okay no [ __ ] it's
January Harrison please nerf Leroy no no
that won't work ok mr. Hirata I am
seventh queue and
Tech and expertise tells me that you
should nerf Leroy please and thank you